voici speedy graphito drôle de pinceau
que cet oiseau interview soap un lapin à
speedy graphito ça te fait chier quand
on est avec toi graffiteurs ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
parce que graffiti c'est un petit truc
et la peinture c'est un grand honneur et
je suis un retard this way en fait a
quand même été connue avec les trucs au
pochoir sur les murs de paris dont il a
ajouté quand même point voiture quand
même je regrette pas mais c'est bon ça
fait ça suppose qu'il quatre ans que j'y
passais un set pochoir sur elle et sur
une map paris c'est l'histoire ancienne
et quand on me parle de la rue à faire
dans cette fesci
ouais hein et enfin pourquoi cette
fichiers ça sera pas prise jack lang
syne avoir huit ont payé une belle
affiche lui ça la culture a vite fait
pas compte encore développer une belle
affiche et donc j'ai fait une belle
affiche pour eux c'est tout quoi bref je
regrette d'avoir fait ça non je préfère
faire ça que pour un yaourt été assez
habile avec les médias quand même temps
d'abord tendance qui dit grafite on sait
bien évidemment l'agitation des matches
comme ça un bip ainsi tu veux pas qu'on
parle de graffitis maintenant c'est vrai
que les parfaits et des noms samedi
bardy sens pas mal ouais c'est pas assez
moins commercial a changé un alléchant
sous les rires et les trottoirs sol
[ __ ] magazine aussi speedo way qui
attaque voire complètement le trajet vu
ce magazine mais j'en revenais pas assez
longue date à ce mal être s'est il ya
des jeux c'est le magazine du fan club
avec des t-shirts ya marchandising
d'enfer pour tous les fans annonce une
dizaine demande pas où j'ai commencé à
recevoir des lettres de fans et pour
leur fair-play savez communiquer avec
eux donc j'ai pris un magazine les gens
revoient attroupement gratuitement c'est
vrai mais prévient françois niveau qui
fait des jeux à 1
je serai pied si tu étais pas ce pays du
golfe
d'abord je n'aurais pas quelqu'un
d'autre tu pars en bloc
non on vous la main que tu as bien
raison j'aime bien mais vous perçu à
l'étranger pas à bord étaient influencés
par quoi rabea benjamin fois que j'ai
des robes de la marque en déminant lui
faisait bien belles bécanes en répudiant
du salagou lâches qui était beaucoup de
lui dire non je me lasse assez vite la
bd cette influence est un peu
cette addition d'individus sera très
intéressante parce que perdu se dit qu'à
ce qu'il faut lire la première deuxième
troisième
ortaffa doute à tout et pour tout dans
une seule image fort et l'art maya s'est
inspiré le pré colombien eric ella a
spec faouzi des tués mais qu'en même
temps on fait un tableau
parce qu'il n'avait fini que je vais
vite là ça dépend ça peut être choses un
peu plus comme
et toi qui se place t il d'autres c'est
pas trois quatre cinq jours seulement du
cher non ah bon c'est normal je suis
attention que ce soit pas trop cher
parce que
c'est bien de pouvoir rendre un peu
ce soit pas un truc là
je sais
c'est pas cher et gens pensent que c'est
pas bien tout c'est ça ouais mais ça je
m'en fous ça bah tant pis pour les cours
est sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux